this is a production of Cornell
University
I would love to welcome everyone to
Cornell University New York today
excellence devastation for the College
of Agriculture and life sciences at
Grinnell my name is Kristine smart and
I'm the director of the school of
integrated plant sciences our hope for
today is actors to dream now everyone I
mean it we're going to introduce story
of that chemistry at Cornell well at
least those books are here and then and
then you know we'll have some describe
some of the research what's happening
but my goal is really to have folks out
in the field looking at the hands and
interacting with our health team so once
you know what goes do you have a
question about you know the overall
project I'm to be honest I'm pretty much
the administrator of the project and a
lot of the other folks here are doing
some of the research so you know if you
have questions about economics you can
pop in and join who you'll meet if you
have questions about the varieties we
have here we have experts on that and so
I hope I always think it's supposed to
be out and walking around the plants and
asking questions they're a circle so
Europe I don't have that I don't
actually have a copy of you
but I'm going to go in uh Jamie right so
what we have out here is a variety trial
and the trial is planted at six
different locations for near the Ithaca
campus and to here up in Geneva and
Jamie Crawford is here come on okay me
and she works for example I am and who
is one of the co leaves on the project
and she'll talk briefly about the trial
and there's a handout there's a handout
if you don't have that we can pass those
around
so change the plan - ever offered online
he was very excited to be here as we
walk through all of you today but um
when we first got swag enormous progress
or an adventure but we were able to line
up the cevis team different varieties
will be set up will be out here in the
trials today so up you want to grab a
handout after you I got here a little
late I apologize for that so on you can
de you know will see the 13 different
rings you'll put driving and then we've
got four different parts private to just
frying baby's father price that we're
testing
on the on the front of the page we've a
little bit of information on the
different trials right and plan TV and
the sort of soils that are in those
locations sort of everything from very
well drained so so like I broadly feel
in a family feel and then it got some so
much early same spot or also so I'm just
sort of see the full spectrum of how all
these different locations so for our
trial where we planted them and four
foot by twenty foot walk and there will
be big yield estimates from we aim for
and except for one where we notice oil
past really kinda need so farmers are
going to want to know something about
McCoy our clients and that and that that
could be a happy visit reinforce creator
form to death and even if that has been
planting that provides for establishment
because we had a closed mouth right
after planting and a rain so so if you
guys have plant forms before you know
you don't want to plant it before the
football trap right and but has it's
even more sensitive and so we have a
good establishment and all of our child
except for the one where it got down
into the 40s with a cold rain afterwards
and so our first child we have about an
average of twelve plants per square foot
and then the second one is closer in
size you know they're only planted five
days apart but that got three days when
we're after is really important so on I
mean I can tell you a little bit about
our other trials around the state you
can see the one behind years at this
which is very nice so now it's we'll
probably got some of our other one
and then I thought okay it mainly want
you introduce yourself said yes so I
only answer research and the health
research answer in the summer
so with the help of our seriously that
is liking that on all of our child in
any ability to the Henryville on weekly
basis these data include neck on hikes
and and flowering as you can see all
varieties are in bloom now even if I
burn brightly three seven red blue
what's later in the people holding that
I've noticed is at the Monte six ready
for transplants that have male and
female 10 or male female parts on the
Pampas a plant flower later in
relationships right money society often
seek out slower but must stay here with
a more linear growth rate than the
nicest right the basic ready have have
had a growth spurt earlier in the season
which is declined since the thirties
Clark this pattern of growth of creating
major differences in height between the
money system value system the money to
drag on pretty much all of our files are
between one and three feet taller and
like when something that we've also
learned for doing these files they're
far and then establishments crucial have
feelings therapy as I see the soil pipe
implanted evening on some effect on
establishment
as we mentioned there first of all this
plant is subscribing earlier in our
recently trial but the establishment
difference is huge and on average our
first trials almost two feet taller and
the classical trial perhaps the planting
baking another event we couldn't pull
new five-day different but the plants
are much shorter and now having trouble
up competing the in Ithaca trial also
didn't get the semi additional pounds
the fertilizer which may have a strong
effect estate that happens very heavy
Peter and our first child also planted
following alfalfa they're planted Alcock
they're planted every year so that may
also make a huge difference our late is
a good trial second trial and twenty
gallon field this plant with just a day
after the first grandchild their agenda
but on average is about seven inches
taller we're not sure whether or not
specific soil type or amount of rain we
follow up on fighting the gradient
surface trial and it's been some time
like this color is the fall when 70% of
the seeds are mature which will be very
soon food and the fiber trial will be
harvested between flowering and feedback
which probably have insulation are your
notes or your notes posted on the
website
among those little nuggets not yet we
don't have any to definitive data yet so
these are some of the observations that
we've made that we are you know we would
have to do what college
and when you said fertilize was triple
or so in this trial 30 pounds per acre
at the 10 20 points and then after they
were up 60 pounds totally that's
consistent at all in the collocations
are just here well so I have another
trial on another farm here in Geneva and
we put triple 19 incorporated that at
Atlantic and it was it based on soil
test you're trying to balance everything
out that way or or we do it as
fertilizers for the part of the research
20 years okay let me introduce myself
I'm Larry smart I'm professor and Geneva
program leader in the horticulture
section at the school of integrated
plant science and I also hold it join
1,400 plant breeding a question was
about fertility initial set of trials we
wanted to keep it fairly simple so we
tried to standardize it with the
fertilization project that would
certainly be an important topic that we
want to look at and the freewill trial
is organic
okay I'm going to get what we're doing
that's that's straight manure when
you're saying or gas yeah there's no
it's on certified organic ground the
only fertilizer this beyond there is
manure hey fish chicken manure compost I
kind of cover crops
let me also say that Jan Gilbert Jenkins
at our school is due
so I just want to talk a little bit
about how the governor Commissioner has
hired me to have a midlife crisis here
although I did buy a yachtie convertible
Express my role in an appointment I've
been working for 20 years Willa
bioenergy crops which you can see over
there that's a two year old standard
willow but in March we held a half
summit that the lieutenant governor
attended on the campus where she
announced four hundred thousand dollar
research grant to Cornell and I thought
that's great you have a very strong
multidisciplinary team and we'll be able
to get some good research done here over
this year next year and we were gearing
up for that planting all these trials
and then in the beginning of June the
governor said well we need more than
just a few variety trials we need
thousands of acres of happen in your
city you want to be a leader in the
country income production and those of
us on the Hampton team at Cornell said
we'll do the best we can
and we started working together with Tim
Sweeney and Jackie show and Chris globe
and see congrat net added markets and
the Commissioner and we were able to
secure a $900,000 grant through Empire
State Development that contract just to
give you an idea of the timeline that
contract was signed on June 16 Janie and
and her colleague Julie Hanson and if
occur worked very art with Valley bio
and Ontario to order more than 51
thousand pounds of
normally bio of the cultivar Anka which
you see here in the trial and then we
work together with eigen markets to line
up growers and some of those Rovers are
here today might Gardner from farm-fresh
first is planted nearly 600 acres ok
dance Pope is here from e-commerce and
they will have 120 acres planted here
buddy
by the weekend hopefully it can in
totally we will have planted 1700 acres
variety across 25 different farm
settings so I have a handout here just
summarized in that our main aim of that
project is to get growers inspired and
also to inspire the markets perhaps and
to send the message that New York is
into them in a big way
with strong support from our academic
institutions Cornell or SUNY colleagues
we will get some data on establishment
methods because all these growers have
used different feeders we stand one
thing we standardized what's the seeding
rate at 30 pounds per acre although
we've got three different feed Lots
which have different germination rates
so that's one of the issues with hemp
that Alan Taylor's going to talk about
is the variability in germination rates
and key Limburger some of our growers
are doing some no-till planting some are
going
one of our growers planted with an onion
planters Margarethe our perfect baby
green which is becoming quite an item
apparently some of them will I think be
able to combine their fields and we'll
be able to measure yield on a fairly
large scale but some of the fields are
still to be planted and those fields are
effectively client of the cover comment
at this point so that's where we stand
with the farmer research trials they
also have judge read from Cooperative
Extension and we have a team of eight or
ten poking out from across the state to
help support those farmers and to learn
more about mountain so that they have a
strong support network as we move
forward
Krister can you introduce yourself so do
you want me to do that boy is no success
and actually after you're finished maybe
if we could just have the extension
folks that are here introduce themselves
sure I think you did good morning
everyone my name is Justin Reid with
Cornell competition team called harvest
New York the end to work at look at new
emerging crops
emerging markets and do a lot of we do a
lot of work for starters in terms of the
analyzing value chains for New York
farmers and so industrial not being a
new problem really fit into that the
type of working with you so how they can
find Cheryl there who works out of our
area Tony office put together a
a report and economic report on the
potential industrial happen in New York
State this is available at domina on the
table where you sign it I encourage you
to grab that on your way out of the day
what we try to do is look at what is the
potential of industrial hemp or of your
father's in terms of was returned per
acre and to do that we needed to begin
to look at what is yield per acre
what is the fighters need what are the
input talking and the first thing you'll
notice we look at our reports that
there's not a lot of data out there some
from different provinces in Canada
Alberta Manitoba material and then just
a few feet as well yield 3 here
somewhere around a thousand pounds
possibly but I've got to believe that
could be higher too if you can't you
need to get us in earlier so that was
really more of a regulatory issue than
an agronomic issue 50 to go see so I'm a
little concerned that any data that you
look at from 2017 does truly reflect the
soil potential office problem
if we were able to get this edit on and
get in the ground earlier I imagine that
that field is going to be a lot higher
the other thing we have to look at when
it comes to yield is what what are we
talking about fiber or mountain without
Steve was the potential market of equity
and that's going to influence our
economics quite a bit since this is a
new problem there's a lot of interesting
other potential uses of it and vari
mentioned beanie greens as well so easy
this is a balanced opponent perhaps
grown in size greenhouses and so I know
there's some market farmers that are
looking at this now and will walk out
and I think 20 P everything some of the
funds that the governor announced on
that second announcement of funding will
probably gonna start looking at finally
has a baby green inside of greenhouses
in Geneva and difficult hopefully will a
production information on answer we also
explore what we use force legality of
that of growing them out as a baby green
selling it to a restaurant actually this
is the most interesting backup I've ever
had I grew a bunch of baby had big green
happen and fell to whatever consumer
whether that's the third thing we wanted
to tour make sure that people understand
that they're navigating those markets of
the progress anything out sessions they
employ workers
there's production specialist here as
well that have more economic knowledge
some of those people are like hunter
reference counting ingredients down to
might be entered some faith as well
there's Mike welcome I'm just a janitor
here right now a people
Jan any other production blocker
extensively loss prevention Peter
carefrontation Peter Landry is our boss
okay so one of the thing that harvest
the earth wants to do is understand
better the profitability of this crop
and do that we need to understand what
are the yield limit right that we've
seen from your Connors so if you're
growing and this year we might expect
they hear from Cheryl fair against what
I work with or Lindsey massive oil for
workers at harvest New York try to
understand the market better what are
the prices received so that we can begin
to create some transparency in value
chain I think one of the real potentials
for this crop is we can grow up there's
probably a lot of other people to grow
up well too but are we going to have
some sort of competitive advantage with
locally big market locally New York baby
prophecies it looks like there's a very
good keep on that bus out there
Chris or Larry
to ask us Jerry talk about the economics
you guys get up close the prices you
guys pay for the vertices anyone yeah I
would say we would so what would we do
to probably update this document we 2017
you data much real dated we get honors
people put themself what my technology
is getting and healthy to stop so should
I divide nine hundred thousand by fifty
thousand did you spend all nine hundred
thousand on
the question is what was that budget of
the nine hundred thousand so these
growers are being compensated by the
acre again affected the seeding rates at
thirty pounds very good so gave them the
exact right amount of feed their target
acreage they're being compensated $400
very group let's that causes the team's
not to exceed $50 per acre so yeah that
word you got the seed for two bucks we
have to take their dollar ninety eight
amount yep Formica including shipping
from Ontario job so let me introduce
professor Gary Bertram in ecology and
kind of apology thanks Larry I get to
see everybody this morning so I'm a
member of me pass a team if you will and
that includes Elson shields and
entomology I don't think Elson could
make it today my laboratory is very
interested in trying to to look ahead to
some of the infectious disease problems
that we may encounter that I sure will
encounter Jamie Cummings here and Kevin
Myers are with my group and we are
looking forward to working with many of
you trying the crop in commercial
production to help you out with
diagnosing problems I attended at our
professional plant pathology meetings
last week through a special session on
have been kind of us general diseases
and one of the things that we heard is
that there's this myth there are no pest
problems cannabis that is quite untrue
and in fact what I heard from how they
can Kentucky Indiana and some other
states that and then may be working on
this a little longer than us that
there's been kind of an explosion of
realizing past problems and down the
road as we increase the acreage in the
in Tennessee we will have a number of
things to deal with and I think as the
course of the morning goes on here if
you don't know already because of the
status of this is a is it really a crop
sort of idea or is it a Schedule one
drug
depending on which which agency you're
talking to there are no registered
pesticides in this problem so in that
sense we're all going to be looking at
organic production
at least the initial years of this and
so that does present some problems some
challenges to us and we'll learn about
that together it means it will be the
work on some cultural practices and
getting things like the sequencing of
crops we want to avoid crops that have
similar spectrum spectrum of diseases
one that we're somewhat concerned about
New York State because of our revisions
is white molds they're getting white
mold because if we're in rotation with
things like soybean a member of our
vegetable crops we already have issues
with that so we know that has quite
susceptible to that but and the other
thing I learned from this
supposin last week that the spectrum of
problems on the greenhouse grown like
for the Bates green is almost completely
different spectrum of problems than what
we encounter in production of the field
so we need to be attuned to that as well
so I'm not going to belabor a lot of
Latin names with you here and a number
of pests that we're going to be on the
lookout for and I just want you to know
that that we're here to serve and work
with you on on diagnosing and learning
together how we can best manage some of
those problems so Thank You Alison all
right you have for introducing yourself
welcome gente it is quite a turnout that
we have given this morning we had just
two ways to go the Indigo the first
you'll say they're ahead about an equal
turnout so really appreciate that the
interest maybe I have a curiosity on
this crowd
so Who am I and my name's Alan Taylor
I'm a faculty here at the Experiment
Station professor and seat Science and
Technology so my involvement in this
project is really looking at the quality
aspects starting to see testing how the
different lines and rise and the out
here but also to go further action
research my research has developed
complete
but I want to thank this person really
beginning this work is really to talk
about seek quality and what does that
mean just again just from the how we
define disease for those are either not
really familiar with agronomic prompts
you all to destroy two components is one
is determination we would all expect
obviously the events of Germany the
second part is called curative appear to
the seed lot is we really just want see
and you open up that bag of Anka to plan
on your farm you want to just account
the seat of that particular variety what
else could be there could be other crops
there can be weeds you to tree noxious
weed seed may be present itself those
leaves meat in there you're also
planning we'd keep in your fund and then
finally just entered matter which is all
just trash material things like that so
there are some standards first of all is
how as we had to import seeds from all
these trial to coming from two main
companies seed companies up in Canada
and the less from from Europe of
learning more about the Canadian system
as there are close neighbors here to the
north personally they have to have an 8
was permitted and heythis permit is a
very general just allows them to export
see there's really no specifications
requirements as far as the germination
is considered a germination test is
performed on the sea also not just we
cannot just read to define invited state
or for the problem to be considered
harmful to agriculture and the only
other thing that's report is if there's
other prophecies in excess of five
percent of quite bills point across
so you say where are these other top
seats coming from Gary mentioned there
are no labels pesticides and that
includes herbicide
so the Grimes death planet I is Michael
loosen my program is here now there are
we found both seed sunflower but we had
a number of different contaminant other
crops these are already present in them
not something it's really nice design so
anyway we are in a point right now out
of just basically of Kevin see important
to us and particulars in New York's
Daniel brought the production of this
product Canada is has some such
standards I want to talk about that they
have a certification we're familiar with
seeing certification here but there's a
little different they have certification
level one number one or number two
so what what is the criteria for them so
if it's a certified number one who the
seed I will have to be over 85 percent
germination that's have three or less we
please present and a 25-grand sample and
then it's less than one o'clock 1:04
left proxy so 25 grams is a lot of shots
also I think everybody can understand
that volume information of what that is
so those are the criterion for number
one if it fails we'll see might even
blow Jenner germination or there's other
more weakly present then the next
category is there number two and that
case the germination needs to be 17
percent or higher and then higher
threshold a number of weeks eat and the
other crop seed would be present so we
have 17 Lots out here I should took 17
full riders but I think really a seed
lot level feedlot level of a variety and
each block can vary from one of those
put in the same variety but of the data
that we collected so far Michael in my
laboratory only 30 percent of those
would have greater than 85
termination and only about half of that
folder 70% so you see it quality to see
that were were important care can be
very very fulfilling very concerned
about that so having a good quality seek
is it's very important to get started on
the right the booklet in communication
was one of the Canadian seed companies
again because they're what even they
call their certified it's not exactly
what we are you find out then you're
going to based on our conversations
actually put on the percent germination
and the thousand three point so again
things that we reduced to on earth ste
tags they do not require that but since
they are exporting that's something that
they had so I think that will be helpful
for next year as we look forward so
again we're focused right now I'm just
doing the standard protein test
following standardized procedures NEC
testing laboratory in the United States
or Canada is following the same rules
but from there we're going to move
forward and looking at see quality and
see bigger aspects can we develop a
practical see make yourself especially
as Jamie's talking about and your
witness soil condition you get a good
spin and the cold white condition you
know the stand is reduced over over
fifty percent so we need to better
understand see quality and other
horrible high-quality feel I I figure
see what really feel like that by that
the standard generations that simply
does not have a college of assault
please Twitter the other aspect is we're
setting up with a fairly weak speed to
begin with once they get established and
growing when they grow pretty vigorously
as you can see out yet but it's that
very early germination early feelings
that is those are the critical stages of
getting up up and growing out of thrown
so so we're interested in kind of the
key technology tools that we're
developing really for small seeded
vegetables and also
organic production of seed enhancements
to try to enhance to stimulate that
early seedling growth but also as you do
not have any chemical seed treatments
that we can use to control fungal
diseases of what can we do can again
going to be organic toolbox and see can
we use that and apply those in supers so
I think for sake of time as if there's
any questions at this time
these are germination rates of the
leaves posted some are not at this time
but we will be doing any work we're
calling a lot of information right now
in the field and elephants and other
girlfriends or so so for all of roll of
postings we've got to go through a whole
process before they're all posted is
like fall or or can you post notes as
you go
always press handle that one key keeping
it so the question was can we talk to
know if there's ago and yet we can make
it
yeah incomplete data is not useful so I
think James you don't have all generates
from all the people on and probably not
useful okay yes and that and what those
will be posted we do have a blog that
Jamie Commons is in charge of and Joey
upsides to coverage and and everything
will be posted on the website
Correll half website and you know that
will go up as soon as possible the only
trick is we're planning for extras right
so then some data right would be helpful
as opposed to waiting for the if it has
to go through a publication process
which I understand has to happen wrong
official stuff but if he night and there
was like a informal okay aligning larger
plant production Eurasian yeah and I'm
happy to have great personal
conversation rather than posting things
really before they're ready
thank you that goes in it and sorry Beth
white yes today while we're here might
often gave me a second you know the hope
is that we'll wander around and you'll
actually be able to talk to the folks
that have a greener and get that
information you can come you know as
preliminary data as soon as you close
something sellable download it and then
they won't have the final version so
that's a bit of a nervousness about our
target but I also want to say to be a
little bit careful high-speed data it's
not the same a variety a doctor because
you know we got to feed lots and a
variety title that were just awful and
it was because we're old feed lot it's
understood anything about those
varieties in particular so we need to
careful about that as well thank you
preserver cooking for very different I'm
not really LM now you talk about seed
enhancement about goofy-looking - okay
so the question is what we call it seed
enhancement see enhance this is kind of
a general term which would be the seed
treatments could be a beneficial seek
treatment such as
trichoderma would be as a seed treatment
to control saw borne pathogens things
like that but we also have what we call
my Oh stimulants which are actually
different natural plant materials to
actually enhance the germination rate
and these two can kind of going concert
together so the ultimate goal here is to
protect but also to enhance the early
termination and stand establishment good
question or clarification
question together we able to desk
generation will different eating
disorder
the question is on my seeing them alert
various abuse and HRT on e85
right so I think because we have the
same variety kinda unfit different sites
will get an idea of that consistency by
variety of cross versus different sites
or rust on your site so I think they're
pretty good replication of that the
salad green is that being grow that
hypertonic revisit the ones that I see
are not drawn hydroponic they're grown
in soft food is that we've seen as well
yeah what we're curious style is Wesley
and the first question would be what's
infertility approach to that and it's
going to be organic inside a greenhouse
that makes a little bit finesse to get
those fulfilled in bubble
recipe particularly around some night
conditions were negative not available
sorry for females are usually on time
for work and professional will be like
are the Canadians going much but we
cookbooks I thought through everything
is for the Pearlman we proceed at some
fiber not food
alright so Peter did you have anything
you wanted to add before I pass it on to
Jackie okay so we're looking at are
there any comments from Phillip field
coming farms you go to build it you want
to draw three controls an issue tell you
I to plants in some of these fields in
the grass and projects you can find it
there there's anybody doing and just
throw in on that topic is that Calvin
has been digging wheat counts in the
general week pressure and there is trial
and it's directly correlated to that
initial stand so as a cultural practice
getting a good initial stand is very
good common issue histories yeah but
very good I showed up today feeling like
wow that was supposed to look laughs so
that was Mike and Gary thing that we
control is definitely an issue and we've
seen that it subsides as well and I
encourage everyone now you know sort of
who knows what that when we begin to
walk around you can ask for more
questions so judges
the formative 8 one thing thanks Chris
morning everyone
it's very exciting for us get out of the
office and come out see the crop in
production and we're very excited about
potential here for this profit to
something emerging for New York State
growers and very thankful to Cornell
layering prison that CCE team for
helping us in this area and also I'd be
remiss if I do not mention our
appreciation concluding words now who
really led the way and a lot of what is
going on now that we have they were
growing last year so we have a little
bit of history not much I'm the
regulator that's here are representing
the regulatory facet of this this has
been a very cumbersome difficult area to
navigate and I also have to take the
time to thanks the Aggie market screen
because while I represent the
Commissioner's Office and the governor
I've got a great group of people and the
Commissioner and the great group of
people behind him and working in office
Kim Sweeney is here who's special
successful Estevez is now targeting
industrial hemp many of you know Chris
globe our division director of Plant
Industry he is up to here in it and then
absolutely while you don't see them
they're very essential and that is our
counsel's office to start out we all
need to know that 2014 federal farm bill
provides a good 40 to State Department
of Agriculture and educational
institutions to conduct agricultural
research projects on industrial hemp and
I have to emphasize the word research on
New York State in the legislature and
the governor signed a couple pieces of
legislation for the laws of the plate
allow us to move forward with pilot
programs
that allow us to grow process they have
a Dell products from those research
projects and LEDs what you've heard here
this morning is our partnership with
Cornell initially with the $400,000 in
these preliminary research trials but
then to take it out in the field and
start gathering some agronomic data on
farms across new york i have to
emphasize that it is the growers
responsibility to identify a feed to
work international seed must be a
painter to eat a authorized source at
the governor's direction the department
is working towards getting a DEA permit
where we will be able once it's in place
to facilitate be coming into the state
from international sources we are in the
process of that we have been in the
process for quite a while on that and
we're hopeful to get that in place so
that we can go out with a solicitation
hopefully towards the fall with enough
time that farmers that are interested
farmers and businesses that are
interested in doing research project and
identity search identifies the source
and then of we would work with them to
facilitate is getting to the farms and
to businesses so we are in the process
of that stay tuned as I said we're
hoping to do a solicitation or to look
for some more research projects on this
fall
being on the sea front we are focusing
our efforts internally on the need for
good viable seed you've heard a lot of
conversations about that here this
morning we're looking at our feet lab
too many to run some tests on some of
those things that Alan has mentioned as
far as germination and there etc we're
also looking and with one of the
initiatives underway
a little time but in speed certification
program in New York State in this area
one of the big things and I forgot to
mention it is this program initially
starting out with ten sites that were
authorized by state law and we as an
agency decided to start out with
educational institutions with them and
had four of those institutions come
forward Cornell being one and then we
look to the tremendous leadership and
getting growers involved and businesses
involved we expanded those names the
private business with the farms the
governor stated they came out but now
we're opening up we need to be growing
looking at this from beyond Penn State
so we do have the ability to expand the
program and but they look at other
research projects we have a working we
also announced an industrial health
working group which is coming together
we hope to have discussions about where
the areas of B are in a research arena
the thing is help guide the needs in C
and as to what kind of projects we look
for and we're also on the processing and
looking for an a rolling kind of
application that's what we're
considering our rolling applications for
processors versus a certain time frame
to grow us you'll have an application
period we're also investigating just a
process or lights just to know where the
processes are where the consistent old
small markets are for the product so
that they are on our radar screen
the there's also through partnering with
entire state development they come out
with processing grants up to $500,000
from processing grant and we're also
working funding from initial
conversations with the Department of
Health with respect of any of the food
supplement area so that's spent on those
conversations and I think that is also
we are regulations that are in place
currently to current started out with
educational institutions or regulations
that are on the books solely pertain to
educational institutions the other
entities that are involved in this
program have been operating under
Department guidance and partnership
agreements with the agency we are
looking to lose that arena into some
kind of regulatory framer framework and
while we're looking at the regulations
we are trying to minimize them so we
initially came out with a program that
had a lot of checks checking the boxes
making sure I think we're fairly much
more comfortable with the program and so
we would be facing potentially making
regulatory changes
lightens up on the regulations that are
in place and also brings the cleanest
guidance into regulation and that's
really sort of protection of everyone
involved body Phillip Schedule one drug
so everyone needs to keep at the top of
their mind in their labor exploring in
Depok attended I'm it's just the
guidance documents being updated you
know should be religious along with the
new application phonetic the so I think
what we're waiting were somewhat sitting
tight because we'd like to give VP a
permit that's really where we are as an
agency we're trying to get to be a
permit we have communication probably
bit have been two weeks got to be a
little don't want to handle too much
behind the very fine line so we're
navigating it we are very diligent I
mean this is coming from the top this is
something that the agency has involved
in in a very big way but it is
complicated and I think we've got a
pretty good job so far everybody
involved has been huge undertaking you
guys have been awesome I I love it one
of the best partnership and you give us
a little bit on you're gonna have a
large volume of testing with these two
thousand acres and there can you give us
a little bit on the state of readiness
we start taking our kids eat us I would
have fortunately I don't have Chris here
with I don't have a plan I think solve
it but a day maybe I don't appreciate
the adventure but I think I have to do
it you know source seed in
comfort level fair we have to make sure
that's another issue that we're working
through it's lab has MIDI and rotate
that is a huge issue it slows and we are
all I can say is we're aware that we are
working every day on that issue the
capability for the regulatory agencies
is for regulatory example and then you
have the whole kind of service sector
that's out there that growers that want
to have their intercom tested and that's
a whole nother reason
oh no way whoops me it's native looking
for those and I was made that design you
know moving across state lines all
across state lines could have you do all
of that in your own room until it to
answer your question a little bit mark
we do have cooperation with our
Institute of biotechnology on the Ithaca
campus to test all the samples from the
six trials all 70 varieties for the
whole cannabinoid spectrum of compounds
and then again in talking with Chris
lobe because Anka is a certified
cultivar in Canada are concerned about
that a little bit less gotcha
yes always a cannabinoid profile we test
flavonoid
oh that's a good question
so I've been even no one that's been
talking to Josh Rose who is the head of
our metabolomic facilities at Cornell
he's a plant biologist in the school of
high sciencism he said that to start
with they're planning to do that
cannibal not get a cannabidiol panel so
more than just the CBD you know a more
broad panel because a lot of folks are
going to want to know you know what all
is available and and that that's not a
regulatory issue that's just an
informational component and and then
once once we determine based on
standards how well we can do then we'll
be able to provide a better idea of the
breadth of testing that can be
and actually they'll actually also be a
protocol for exactly how the samples are
collected in the field for that testing
and our protocol will be identical to
that that egg and market diseases and I
know team are working I know with
wodsworth the program wodsworth we had a
conversation with Chris smart here how
to achieve a consistency well we have
participated and going to other person
country to see how the sample should be
taken once that protocol is determined
we will then be doing outreach to our
force inspectors few keyboard inspectors
that will be responsible for you know
thanks Chris you have any expectations
at the federal level for the next round
oh no I mean I think it's on our you
know we've on our radar see it's
definitely stuff I don't want put words
in anyone's mouth but Thanksgiving to
Governors we're very aware of this issue
and we understand these agree to
foot-in-the-door the Marbella with
industrial hats out but there is a bill
introduced in Congress now to relax some
of the regulations right you know that
may be big enough but the whole thing
we're working under doesn't sunset at
the 2014 right it doesn't have to be
reauthorized or does it affect that
we're just starting I mean we're
starting to look at as a whole as an
agency at a farm bill is starting to
have discussions and it's an expression
for everyone but here in folks Oh point
person on I would guess on federal farm
bill who I worked closely with us in the
commissioner's office would be a farmer
so what we would love to do now is that
everyone to sort of go out and wanted to
the field get questions on p4 Allen on
diseases preparing his team tonight the
whole nana's yeah I've been out the
field we begin with that I get to have
don't please didn't interact with us ask
us any questions you have and enjoy joys
I have
[Music]
watch start okay this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu